do you regret backing out of that bit
where they shot the bullets at you and
the oh not in this way you mean then the
number two yeah oh no we talked about
the sketchy as hell those people i think
they got busted for like meth or
something finally i hope i'm not talking
[ __ ] about something something that
didn't happen but i'm pretty sure those
people are shady they're very they have
weapons they're gonna come after me now
what am i doing no damn it i don't know
what you're talking about yeah we're
good we just made it up anyway
yeah well we had to do the it was like
this riot control thing yeah they put it
on a bird
blast i do not regret backing out of
that yeah you made that even ryan came
up to me he's like that you're smart
that sucked and bam cried
yeah they told they told us it wouldn't
break the skin and they were all just
bleeding like out of everywhere after
that yeah it's called stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude